according to the latest ABC
news/washington post poll Donald Trump's
approval rating down a 36 percent this
is a historic low for all 70 years of
presidential approval polling at the
six-month mark of a presidency of which
we are three days shy today here are the
results from this particular ABC
news/washington post poll if you don't
believe this poll only and we'll keep
this up for people to check out Gallup
has it within the same margin of error
as these results 38% approval for Trump
versus 36% statistically effectively the
same Trump behind only Ford who had a 39
percent approval rating at the six-month
mark of his presidency so we were
wondering how the growing Russia scandal
would affect Donald Trump's approval the
views of the American people on the
Russia scandal are pretty interesting
63% of Americans almost two-thirds
believe that that meeting that Donald
Trump jr. had with the Russian lawyer in
Trump Tower was inappropriate 60 percent
believe that Russia tried to influence
the campaign this is low and Trump's
approval has already been down to 36%
before and this was undeniably
on a totally inappropriate meeting with
the Russian lawyer Russia undeniably
tried to interfere in the election we
have written evidence of that now and as
more people find out I can only assume
that it's at minimum not going to help
Donald Trump's approval rating and it
will likely hurt it the health care
proposal to repeal and replace Obamacare
that's not helping by a two-to-one
margin Americans prefer Obamacare which
we have now to the latest version of the
American Health Care Act and what Donald
Trump's reaction
he's calling 36 percent 40 percent and
he's saying 40 percent is pretty good he
took to Twitter the other day over the
weekend and said quote the ABC
Washington Post poll even though almost
40% is not bad at this time was just
about the most inaccurate poll around
election time I thought Trump
went to Wharton School of Business at
the University of Pennsylvania would
they agree that forty or rather 36
percent is not bad at any point I don't
think so Pat he has been having some
issues when it comes to math and
remember this is the president who
asserts that he would have won the
popular vote had three to five million
people not voted illegally yeah and now
he has this so-called voting election
commission going on to uphold our
integrity and he has Mike Pence and
Chris Kobach working hard on that but
you'd have to imagine that if there was
so many people voting illegally and
voting for his opponent that his job
approval numbers would be so much higher
now right because the election results
where he lost the popular vote by three
million would not reflect the will of
the people who really really liked the
job he's doing no no indication of that
whatsoever and the really sad situation
is that 36 percent of the country still
approves that the job Donald Trump is
doing that means if you go to three
random people obviously depends on where
in the country you are but in total
victory random people from our country
statistically one of those people is
going to say I approve of the job that
Donald Trump is doing and the obvious
question is what exactly is it that you
approve of and how does this affect his
ability to govern that is the key sort
of political question an unpopular
president means number one fewer people
feel the need to make a deal with him or
help him if he stays at 36% or drops it
becomes more and more likely that
Republicans will actually turn on him
for their own self-preservation and
we're starting to see more and more of
that happen in what other job would you
have a 36 percent approval rating or
maybe it would be a customer
satisfaction rating in a job and spend
22 percent of your time playing golf and
be allowed to keep your job not too many
jobs would let you get away with that